why are Chris Pratt and Anna Faris
calling it quits is nothing sacred
anymore hey guys this is the daily Denny
today I'm in all black because I am
mourning true love after eight years of
marriage Chris Pratt and on Affairs have
split the surprising breakup rocked
Hollywood and it shook me my night was
ruined after Chris and honor shared a
joint social media statement announcing
their legal separation saying they tried
hard for a long time and were really
disappointed
they added they're hoping to keep things
as private as possible moving forward
for the sake of their son Jack now it's
suggested hectic work schedules calls
and split with on a shooting season five
of her CBS sitcom mom and Chris of
course traveling the globe for his
blockbuster films but another major clue
into their separation while we were with
Anna just two weeks ago at the premiere
of her emoji movie with her son Jack
Chris was nowhere in sight even though
he was home in LA after wrapping
production on the drastic world sequel
but just watched Honor's reaction at the
mention of his name even Chris they're
both rats have you been celebrating
having some quality time it's been
awesome yeah yeah yeah
the couple's last appearance together
was in April at the guardians of the
galaxy to premiere and then just two
days later at Chris's Walk of Fame
ceremony where at the time they looked
very much in love I'm telling you guys
they were a couple we were rooting for
mostly because their marriage seemed so
unhallowed here's further proof watch
how much they gushed about each other to
our cameras I'm so so beyond proud and
I'm thrilled to be here with him and by
his side and I am I just you know I
can't believe that a
and my husband is a movie star it's nice
to have a your family with you because
it it it brings you to earth it brings
you down to earth and when you're when
you can touch you leave your feet on the
ground you get to actually experience
what it feels that have your head in the
clouds
I'm so proud I'm so proud I feel like I
saw it early on and I'm just so proud
that and if so deserve it because he is
just a great man and he's a great actor
and I am just my heart just burst with
pride I've heard some people say don't
go to bed mad
I think that's garbage sometimes you got
to go to bed mad but at least touch the
toes you know I mean at least just touch
toes and I know we'll deal with it later
I'm going to get some sleep touch toes I
guess the road to John and Chrissy
perfection is bleak and not everybody
can hang the legends you our only hope
actually one couple still going strong
is Beyonce and jay-z lord knows their
stuff has been playing out and their
music but over the weekend the Carters
hit the roller rink like a couple of
teenagers and love looks like Beyonce
did most of the skating though she and
jay-z's hit up world on wheels here in
LA beyonce posting a little bit on her
instagram and eyewitness says she came
in low-key rocking a black magic shirt
and started skating with everybody else
until they realized it was her but don't
worry the ring stayed open so she and
her entourage could skate meanwhile over
in New York City it was another day
another low-cut sexy dress for JLo Jenny
from the block knows how to clean up and
this time it was as a Ross one to a
wedding let's be real how you going to
invite Jennifer Lopez to your wedding
you're just asking to be upstaged
especially where she shows up in this
$1,300 heeled gown by Hamill the high
neckline was enough to be proper the
side cut up or enough for a double take
but the whole look was enough to remind
everyone why JLo is winning life right
now so j-rod they look like they're
going strong and I want to say they're
in for the long haul
but who even knows anymore in other
breakup news Aaron Carter called it
quits from his girlfriend Madison Parker
et confirmed the split exclusively with
a source telling us the breakup was
amicable and quote aaron is continuing
to focus on his personal cell with
regards to his truth health and use it
well Aaron is certainly living in his
truth because the 29 year old also took
to Twitter and opened up to his fans
about his sexuality revealing that
around 13 years old he started to find
boys and girls attractive Aaron went on
to say he had an experience with a male
he'd grown up with and worked with when
he was 17 and admitted this had been
weighing on him for nearly half of his
life quote this doesn't bring me shame
just a weight and a burden I have held
on to for a long time interesting enough
Aaron was just telling et last month he
wanted to propose to Madison in the
future in five years from now where do
you see Aaron Carter where are you going
to be in your life I want to be married
I'm going to be engaged to my beautiful
girlfriend version I want to be a good
father a good role model a strong role
model well folks when it comes to love
and life I guess lives are just like us
hopefully Bachelorette Rachael Lindsay
will be luckier than the rest of us head
over et's community tab to cast your
vote on who you think Rachael will give
the final rose to on tonight's
Bachelorette finale I will be watching I
will be drinking wine while before recap
for you guys tomorrow so be sure to hit
subscribe and stick with ET online.com
because we are all over the Chris Pratt
on Affairs news today all right I'm
going to go dry my tears